Christian Elder, Screenwriter:
It is absolutely, absolutely
paramount that every writer get to that space…
Film Courage:
Should someone be fearful with building their
entertainment career or at least cautious?
Christian: Yeah I guess so but you know mostly
be fearless because what I mean by that is that
there are so many forces that want to
strip you of your voice as a writer
and to make you compromise that voice and to
make undermine that voice and confuse you into
thinking that you should undermine your voice and
that's ridiculous, that's absolutely ridiculous.
The greatest writers in screenwriting
we know who they are simply because
not only when we read the scripts you know
their voice is apparent and rises to the
surface but when we see the finished products,
it's apparent. I mean it's like how do you how
do you separate you know I mean you know the sound
of Tarantino, it's like you know I mean, it's like
you know the sound of Diablo Cody, you know the
sound of of Spike Lee. These people have sounds,
that's your voice and if you're not working, if
you're not sharpening your quiver to towards that
direction then you're not going to ever sort
of stand out from the crowd because that's
what ultimately is the goal, that's what makes if
we're going back to our Michael Clayton analogy,
that makes you the commodity that cannot be
avoided, that that people have to come to.
In the end it's going well we need
him to do this, we need to call up
oh I'm forgetting her name
it's a Phoebe Waller-Bridge,
we need to call her to punch up a
script because we need that voice
and all you need to do is say her name and you
know what her voice means to that to that project.
It is absolutely, absolutely paramount
that every writer get to that space
because then you know people, you
know agents, producers, executives,
they get bombarded with crap, they get
bombarded with a lot of the same of this
or a lot of or people people that sound like
saying back people that sound like this you
know people like you know that's you know that
want to be David peoples people that you know
and they don't really want that,
they want to know who you are,
they want something that's so unique and that
they can go oh well you know nobody else has that,
so this is the one-stop shop where you can go
to, you only can go to that store to get that,
I think writing screenplays specifically is a
love for the art, storytelling yeah, yeah and
that sort of dovetails to what I was discussing
before a little bit with mining the written word
but also just to elaborate on that it's really the
classic example of having that command of telling
a story around a campfire and to take people
through a journey that that keeps them entertained
but also leaves them with something something that
sort of delights them in a special way, that is
The Art of Storytelling that is the thing that has
occurred time and memorium since the cavemen were
drawing on drawing on the sides of the caves.
That's what I'm speaking of, I'm speaking to
and that's what you do with the screenplays,
the first the first brick in building that wall,
the wall where it will be projected eventually.
The theater is the big cave that we all
huddle inside. I like that so it's not just the
love of the final product which is seeing these
characters come to life and getting an audience
reaction to will they laugh at this part,
will they gasp at this part but also just the
real love for crafting it and ruminating over
this word or should this character enter here or
there well I think that all filmmakers and what I
mean by all filmmakers is that all crafts people
in the art of filmmaking from the writer, to
the production designer, to the actor, to the
director to hopefully the producers have a passion
for telling stories and that's where everyone
collaborates, that's where everyone comes together
because they go how can we tell this
story in the best possible way because
everyone's excited about that prospect and that
notion it's larger than any one one person's
aspect on the production is no one is the sole
avatar of that of that objective. It's like
oh how can we tell this this great story we're
all excited about, how can we succeed at that?